(audience applauds)
I'm applauding for you.
I am applauding for you.
Congratulations. That is major.
I couldn't be more proud to witness such
a life-changing full circle moment for you.
This is a full circle moment for us
because we've known each other
for so many years
and worked alongside of each other on SNL
for what feels like decades,
and it might actually be decades.
Now, is this your childhood bucket list dream,
like me with magazines?
Did you always dream of having like your very own
with your name, network television show?
I mean, it's one of those, you know,
ultimate goals you never think is going to really happen,
you know, like getting on SNL in the first place, but yeah.
The fact that it's all happening now,
and it wound up being titled underneath my very first name
is just the ultimate, you know, achievement
I think for a comedian to have a sit-com
and have it be received well, you know,
and that's what's happening right now.
Everybody seems to be digging the show
young, old, white, black, you know, whoever.
So it's a beautiful time.
Can you explain, like
'cause you have all that Good Burger, SNL,
you have such a large resume and roster of successes.
What is different about this?
This is me on blast.
Like up until this point, I've been very ensembled,
you know and I'm a big fan of the ensemble,
you know, approach to delivering entertainment.
And once again, I'm surrounded by beautifully, beautifully
talented, wonderful, awesome people.
And I get to talk about them and promote them
on awesome shows like yours with another beautiful soul
who kind of, you know, I wouldn't say kind of,
you actually know the struggle of a child actor going
into adulthood and how scary that can be,
and also how to just stay creative
and stay putting things out.
So the fact that you have a magazine coming out,
and you're doing furniture and pots and pans.
Totally, I am pots and pans! I'm Mrs. Pots and Pans.
A thousand percent! Like I just, I couldn't be prouder
that you're that shining example for, you know,
somebody like myself is, you know,
seeming very busy,
but also there's so much more that can be done
if you're willing.
You are the father of two daughters,
and you play the father of two daughters,
but I read a detail that really intrigued me,
which is you play a widow,
and you were influenced a little bit
by Patton Oswalt's story. Is that correct?
You know, he was kind of a close example to that.
Thank God I have an example like his
from a person like him who is so gracious and so intelligent
and so full of heart and emotion that I can experience,
you know, kind of like the full journey because he is so
like forward with it.
Like he talks about it in a stand up and stuff like that.
So, he is very sharing with that experience.
So, I'm just, I'm grateful that I was able to be able to,
like, tune into him to kind of understand what
that experience might possibly even be like
Your show deals with being a widow, raising two daughters,
being a television host.
Why did you decide to bring in the inevitability
of life of comedy and tragedy into the show?
I just was looking for a way to stand out, like kind
of not your typical cookie cutter everything's hunky-dory,
let me just complain
about the mailman being late type of sit-com.
That's what I love about it,
and I was so captivated when you have that breakdown
on camera, and I just thought the writing was so crisp
and your performance was so beautiful.
And I do feel like life is comedy and tragedy.
You play a TV morning host.
Yeah, you hear me?
I love that word, sort of pretending to be the same thing.
Drew, you and I are the same.
My pots and pans are coming to Walmart in the fall.
Bring it!
Bring it! Kenan,
I would run to the top of any mountain for you.
I would move mountains for you.
I always will.
(happy, energetic music starts)